[Music]
minnesota is known as the land of 10 000
lakes and this time of year most are
frozen deep that makes them safe enough
not only for ice skaters but for a
competition you might not expect to see
on the ice john lauritsen of our cbs
station wcco has the story
if it's 20 below we're over here it'll
be 40 above we'll be out here when you
see a group of people on a minnesota
lake in february you naturally assume
they're there to ice fish
but for six weeks in the winter
this lake transforms into a frozen oasis
for race car drivers
it's cold
it's fun it's something crazy and
different whenever i tell someone about
it they always they can't comprehend
that it's on a lake
[Music]
it all began 25 years ago when chad
erlinson and his buddies realized they
missed dirt track racing so to get
through the quiet of winter they decided
to get loud
[Music]
a bunch of us kind of got together and
started racing with another group and
since then it's just been kind of
growing and going and going
now they have eight different classes of
cars there are those with studs in them
and those without
trucks and side by sides also get a
chance to take home the checkered flame
it's throttle control and having
patience and trying to go as fast as you
can without sliding out
when the temperature plummets and the
winds pick up it's also nice to have a
pit crew you know chad's daughter haley
helps him get ready i love being with
friends and family out here
then there are the coring sisters twins
jennifer and chantelle are from fort
ripley minnesota our dad helped start
the organization so he used to blame for
all of them
the ice changes by the hour which
impacts performance
speeds can reach 80 miles an hour
of course when you go that fast things
don't always end well as i found out
while riding shotgun
to be good at this you have to drive a
lightweight car that means making
adjustments to make your car as light as
possible that includes tearing out the
dash the back seats and the back
windshield
rear windshields are overrated anyway
you got nothing back here to protect you
no we tough it out for all the cold yeah
for sure
the good thing is if you do spin out
there's a nice soft snow bank waiting
for you and a tow truck is always nearby
ready to help we used to race with the
dads and now the sons daughters are out
there racing with them and everything
else too john lordson cbs news garrison
minnesota
you guys want to race i really want to
try what do you think that's an accident
waiting to happen if you ask me i want
to talk but an incredible scene
oh definitely